hello and welcome again to a tutorial on
a new competition that we have recently
published
this time we are selecting heads of
administration in eu delegations
a delegation is kind of an embassy of
the eu in a third country so not in an
eu member state but in a country outside
of the eu
we have as usual published an
infographic on our website which shows
you in a blink of an eye the eligibility
criteria and the different stages of the
competition
and in this tutorial i will give you
some more in-depth information on these
different stages
of the competition
when it comes to eligibility this
competition is published on great ast 4
which basically means that either you
need
post-secondary education and six years
of experience in the field
or secondary education and nine years of
experience in the field
when i say in the field it has to be a
field which is listed below one of the
fields listed below and there's quite a
choice for this competition
so your degree and your experience
should be in either law
hr
accounting engineering business
administration
finance logistics or building management
you have quite a choice here
to choose from then there's also a
language criterium of course your first
language can be any of the 24 official
languages
your second language must be either
english or french
now
personally i think it's quite an
exciting position i'd like to compare
these heads of administration with a
swiss knife they are
multi-tools you know they are also
multitasking heads of administration run
the day-to-day business of a delegation
so they are involved in hr matters in
project management in security in
building management
so they are they have really kind of an
extensive portfolio
to take care of
the selection procedure is quite
standardized as you may have seen in
previous
tutorials so once you have applied
you are invited to a first stage of
testing
where we test your reasoning skills
second stage is a talent screener i will
explain in a minute what that entails
the last stage is an assessment center
where we test a set of competencies
the successful candidates are listed on
a reserve list of successful candidates
and those are the ones that then will be
recruited
into these delegations
so let's have a closer look at these
different stages
application of course starts with an
epso account if you do not have an exo
account yet you can easily create one if
you do have one use that account to
apply do not create a new account
because you can only have one account
you only need one account for all your
applications with eu careers
you can only apply online on our website
obviously and you have to apply
or you can apply in any of the 24
languages
apart from the talent screener part
which you have to fill in english i will
explain in a minute what this is
you should validate your application by
the 27th of september so you have quite
some time to do so
you don't have to apply in one go you
can start your application save your
your entries and then come back at a
later stage just make sure that you
validate your application at the latest
on the 27th of september
everybody who applies will be invited to
the first stage of testing which is a
test where we test your reasoning skills
we test your verbal numerical and
abstract reasoning skills
in your language one
you see the number of questions we we
ask you you see the duration you get to
solve these questions
you need a combined pass mark of at
least 20 out of 40
combined meaning that you could
fail for one of these tests as long as
you make up for your
scoring in the other tests you need at
least 20 out of 40.
i do strongly advise you to train this
and you can do so by having a look at
our sample tests which are available on
our website
you can test this in any of the 24
languages
and by doing so you will get better at
this because first of all there is the
level of difficulty of these questions
but there's also this time factor
involved and by rehearsing this by
practicing this you will get better at
this and you will
improve
if you pass this stage you will be
invited to the second stage
which is the talent screener phase
you yourself you don't have to do
anything anymore because you have filled
this
face when you applied
so what happens now is that the
selection board will check your answers
to the questions in this talent screener
the talent screener is a set of 10
questions where we assess your
professional experience in these
different fields you know the different
aspects of the job of a head of
administration
the selection board will rank
all the candidates
through the answers given by the
candidates and the best ones ranked will
be invited to the third stage of testing
which is the assessment center
first we test a set of general
competencies seven of them you see them
listed on this slide here
and we do so by
having the candidates sit two different
tests
the case study which is a written
exercise will test four competencies
and the situational competency based
interview will test three more
competencies okay
again you need a combined pass mark of
35 out of 70 you get
maximum 10 points per competency and you
need at least 35
all over
then of course we also test your field
related competencies and this is done by
a field related interview so again an
interview with the selection board
which you sit again in french or english
by the way your general competencies are
also tested in your second language
english or french
for the field related competency tests
you need also at least 50 out of 100s
and the score combined
general competencies and field direct
competencies will give you the final
mark
and the best ranked people will be the
ones who are the successful candidates
we're looking to select 40 successful
candidates and these are the ones that
then will be offered the job in these
delegations
please do read the notice of competition
carefully the notice of competition is a
legal document explaining the whole
competition the duties the eligibility
criteria the different steps of the
competition explained in detail again so
please
read this document carefully if you
would still have questions after that
you can of course always reach out to us
through the web form on our website and
we of course will be happy to answer all
your queries
i hope this was useful please do apply
and hopefully you can join us later on
as one of our successful recently
recruited heads of administration in a
delegation thanks for your attention and
see you next time bye